so here's a weird one did you know that
Dragon Ball has a spin-off manga
centered around Yamcha sort of the manga
was called that time I got reincarnated
as Yamcha no really it's a parody on the
isakai genre and features a young fan on
Dragon Ball who trips down some stairs
and wakes up as Yamcha in the world of
Dragon Ball you know like other great
works of the genre like reborn as a
vending machine that's a real thing it
sounds kind of silly at first but
honestly the manga extremely rules the
kid uses his knowledge of Dragon Ball
like we all would to work his way
through the world safely traveling
Dynamic and getting a power up from Guru
before facing off against Vegeta and
ends up beating him by well yeah I won't
say anymore because you should
definitely read it yourself the artwork
is really fantastic and the story is
surprisingly compelling oh and uh the
kid gets to see bulma's boobs good on
him I guess